joshua's in phoenix hey joshua how are
you
good how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
so i recently graduated college back in
may
and i've recently found your podcast
around a month ago and i'm currently on
baby step two
great um i have around 36 000 in debt
9 000 of which is a car loan and
27 000 in student loans i just wanted
your advice
on how to tackle this um i
was thinking about selling that car i
can sell it for around 14 to 15 000.
um or just paying that nine thousand off
um and also
paying off my student loans yeah that's
what i would do what do you make
what's your income uh i make around um
pre-tax eight thousand a month oh you're
killing it man
i would keep that car you don't need to
move down a car but you do need to get
on a written budget
and completely lean in and do nothing
with money but pay off debt
hard and fast fast as you can like your
life depended on it
okay so i do have thirty thousand in
savings oh good write a check and pay
attention
uh pay off the car pay off pay off the
car and put the rest of it on the
student loan down to a thousand dollars
because you only have thirty five or
thirty 36 000 in debt
and so you're going to be out of debt
like three months two months
okay um so let me recap let me recap
the shortest the shortest distance
between where you are
and wealth is debt-free
and that's why i'm doing this it feels
herky-jerky to you and you're in love
with your 30 000
savings account so this when i just said
this your head just spun around twice
right yeah okay so
but knowing what i know
having lived as long as i've lived and
as many people as i've gotten out of
debt and
taught him how to be wealthy and me
included and chris included
we know that we as fast as we possibly
can need to get rid of the debt
and then very quickly rebuild your
emergency fund you need
three to six months of expenses
emergency fund you make eight thousand
dollars a month okay
you're in good shape man you're killing
it what's your career
i'm in uh mortgage okay good you're
doing great
so here's the thing you pay off the car
and we put 20 and we and we put i see
you said you had 30 is it actually
exactly 30 000 that you have
um i have around uh 30 000
and 500. okay good all right so baby
step one is a thousand dollars i want
you to leave a thousand dollars in there
which gives us
twenty nine thousand five hundred
right okay that pays off nine thousand
dollar car
that leaves me twenty thousand and five
hundred which means you have 6
500 left on your student loan does that
sound right to you
yeah if you do that if you follow that
through and then you're gonna do that
this afternoon if i'm you
okay okay so just leave a thousand leave
a thousand and there's your little baby
starter emergency fund now making eighty
eight thousand dollars and you only got
sixty five hundred dollars in debt
i would expect you to pay that debt off
within two months wouldn't you
two months yeah that's definitely
something i can do
thirty two hundred dollars a month and
you're done then
i want you to save four or five thousand
dollars a month
into that thousand dollar account baby
step three and let's start
raising this back up now walk through
the math with me here for a second
thousand dollars has got your stomach in
your throat
right yeah definitely month one
it's still there but now you got month
two it's still there but now you got
zero debt
and no payments you still with me
yeah month three you're going to put
four thousand dollars into that account
and you're gonna have five thousand
dollars
ninety days from today month four
you following this yeah you're gonna
have another four thousand dollars so
now you're gonna be at
roughly ten thousand dollars in this
account four months from today you're
going to be a hundred percent
debt free with ten thousand dollars in
the account does that feel a little bit
better
that does i think uh what initially held
me back was just seeing all that
savings yeah because it feels like it's
forever and my point is it's
only for four months five months is 15.
six months is 20. seven months is you
know
eight months from today you're gonna
have thirty thousand dollars and no
there you go